some of the funniest political moments
in recent history here we go with that
let's get started Mr fedman we're going
to begin with you your political
experience includes serving as the mayor
of bradoock a small burrow near
Pittsburgh and one term as lieutenant
governor you're running for a seat that
could decide the balance of power in
Washington ites what qualifies you to be
a US senator you have 60
seconds hi good night everybody
it's like you know it's coming you know
I don't know that I can really make fun
of John fedman anymore he is probably
the sanest most functional Democrat in
the entire Senate so good night
everybody love you fetman what's next
who were on the phone listening to the
president talk about this swap of dirt
for US military
aid Chris so far the evidence is
uncontradicted that the president used
taxpayer dollars to ask the Ukrainian to
help him cheat an election and the
complaint that I've heard it's
definitely real they claimed Chris
Matthews who then got fired from MSNBC I
don't remember why claim that it was
because he moved a coffee mug across his
desk but swall farts and moves up in his
chair and he just looks like he's going
to fart he also banged the Chinese spy
and should probably be in jail what's
next daughter oh yeah
grandaughter how about
Penelope well Penelope she she's only
two so I she'd be happy with oh that's
great that's great yeah oh that's
wonderful that you have a 2-year-old
well have a merry Christmas have a
wonderful Christmas and by the way you
guys had to be in bed by 9:00 you know
and asleep between 9 and 12 he doesn't
show
up this isn't to you Jared this is to
the kids that's
right God I hope you have a wonderful
Christmas here it comes yeah I hope you
guys have a wonderful Christmas as well
mer Christmas and let's go Brandon let's
go Brandon I agree hey by the way are
you in
Oregon it's just it's so sad like it
honestly it's funny but it's sad he
doesn't know what he's saying he doesn't
know what he's doing it's Jill is so
much sharper and on the ball she's a
doctor for God's sakes why hasn't she
prescribed him with something let's go
Brandon oh my
God